welcome to this video new Mariano's do I
know this guy Santiago bit wrong way
down okay mMmmm let's do b6 again it
really I really should should learn
something more solid again see formally
once in a while it would make sense I
maybe I should next next time just play
the Queens gambit declined it's really a
good opening only yesterday looked at
this briefly weather with a student of
mine and the Queens gambit declined is
really really solid for like let's see I
want to get this in and be sure six it's
an interesting way to play quite quite
sharp okay not like well sharpest and
this is so you know they know any other
stuff like that but it is an interesting
interesting position trying to get rid
of his d5 corn one point is that Knight
takes e4 Evie for his night really has
no good squares and here he has to think
about the pressure on the center so i
might be able to win the porn if he's
not taking and if he is taking i'm
gaining something yeah now I against
some space yet my next move is possibly
c5 yep let's get sieve Ivan yeah I can
take here I think wait just in just a
moment yeah it's still good the pin the
bishop on g7 is good check oh yes to
take with a king and now knight c6
yeah 96 I guess for Knight a5 also long
castles this is a really nice position
here now white is struggling I've got
the two bishops good center that this is
really nice for me 94 hmm it's not bad
94 I can probably just move the King to
be one let's let's get this in first
yeah yeah I thought 95 would be strong
checking c4 and taking f3 isn't this
strong
hmm yeah maybe this is just evaporating
all right i should have reconsidered
that simply i cannot i cannot cannot
save the exchange yeah what a shame it
was such a nice position okay
ja jam that was it wasn't good young I
should really keep some advantage out of
this opening but not like that I really
don't think I can do anything here
tonight is totally fine you of course
not i'm not a bad piece at all or
anything here for g5
those two pawns as three points c5b 6
and so on this is a slide annoyance that
they want dark squares and maybe this is
what tempts them to to play on
thinking about Bishop b4 to e1 those
kind of ideas
hmm yeah i mean i should have just been
just sorry my voice is failing me may I
should have just played this differently
I'm this Bishop on B forms probably not
the best possible the best possible
placement for the choice check
check check yeah he's forcing a draw
avoiding that is kind of kind of
ridiculous i have absolutely no way to
do it King f6 now okay turn around yeah
this was this was a spoiled chance that
the opening position was of course
really excellent if we look at this yes
is a fantastic position by white has
black has two bishops bit more space
yeah that's very very nice but maybe
this chick I know but long castles looks
good III and here maybe I have to do
something else yeah i know you know i
just i simply simply didn't appreciate
that this is just a total trade with
nine f7 after that we exchanged the
whole board basically and nothing ever
happens probably this is this is good
gaining some space this is what the
computer suggests that is this is
keeping some advantage the space this is
really nice to have so that is probably
the way to go ah yeah it's nothing
concrete but it's a very nice position
to bishops the space White has very
little in terms of active ideas so this
is the way to go the way it went we
really just trade it and traded
everything and I really I didn't have
anything else I mean the easiest is
probably just heck of this night but
it's still a draw and maybe maybe this
yeah yeah it's a draw what can you do
it's just the draw sometimes games are
boring what can you do okay well i hope
you enjoyed it thanks anyway